well Donald Trump has his first serious
Challenger I guess serious in the 2024
Republican primary that Challenger is
former South Carolina governor and
Trump's own former ambassador to the
United Nations Nikki Haley Nikki Haley
was expected to announce uh any day
eventually it became clear that she was
going to announce on February 14th which
is of course
what is it is it like National tea day
or something or that Valentine's Day
um Nikki Haley announcing she is indeed
running for president releasing a
three-minute video which I have to tell
you I don't really understand the case
she's making for her own candidacy
highlighting elements of her biography
but appearing to say I'm more or less
like Trump but younger see if you can
figure out what is the case she's making
here and then we're going to talk about
the Outlook we've got new polling and
we'll tell you where Nikki Haley is it's
all getting very interesting take a look
at this
the railroad tracks divided the town by
race
I was the proud daughter of Indian
immigrants
okay so playing up racial diversity
starting off with that not black
not white
I was different it's enlightened
centrism she wasn't black or white she
was Indian that's an interesting
approach
but my mom would always say your job is
not to focus on the differences but the
similarities
and my parents reminded me and my
siblings every day how blessed we were
to live in America
some look at our past as evidence that
America's founding principles are bad
they say the promise of freedom is just
made up
some think our ideas are not just wrong
but racist and Evil
nothing could be further from the truth
I have seen evil
in China they commit genocide
in Iran they murder their own people for
challenging the government
and when a woman tells you about
watching soldiers throw her baby into a
fire
it puts things in perspective
even on our worst day we are blessed to
live in America
I was born and raised in South Carolina
so I have seen the very best of our
country
people here throughout the old tired
political establishment and demanded
accountability for their tax dollars
industry reports called us the Beast of
the southeast
which I love
people came by the thousands for Fresh
Starts moms and dads held their heads up
high children learned that it was always
a great day in South Carolina it's a
great day it's a great day a great day a
great day in South Carolina
we were strong
we were proud
evil did come
police in South Carolina are looking for
a gunman following a shooting at a
church yeah they when when evil came
they did nothing about gun safety
they're victims we don't know the
severity we turned away from Fear toward
God the values that that's true they did
nothing about the guns and they said we
need prayer thank our Bank our country
the freest and greatest in the
we must turn in that direction again
Republicans have lost a popular vote in
seven out of the last eight presidential
elections that has to change yeah what
may be better candidates and better
policies would help Joe Biden's record
is a business
or again it's time for a new generation
of leadership yeah so it seems to be
basically she's Trump but a new
generation meaning younger to ReDiscover
fiscal responsibility secure our border
and strengthen our country our pride and
our purpose
foreign
[Music]
the Socialists left sees an opportunity
to rewrite history by the way the
Socialists on the screen are Nancy
Pelosi
who known for stock trading uh Joe Biden
a center-left Democrat Kamala Harris
very much not a socialist and Bernie who
while describing himself as a Democratic
Socialist actually really runs as a
Social Democrat the this is the best
they can do when it comes to socialists
China and Russia are on the March they
all think we can be bullied kicked
around
you should know this about me I don't
put up with bullies and when you kick
back
it hurts them more if you're wearing
heels I'm Nikki Haley and I'm running
for president
wow
[Music]
so Nikki Haley is running her for
president if I understand correctly it
is the standard completely generic
boring old right-wing talking points
combined with she's younger and she's
Indian I mean that that's quite frankly
that's my understanding of what she's
saying here now it will be interesting
to see Trump's reaction as of this
moment Trump has not responded to her uh
challenge of Trump's uh Republican
primary and looking on Truth social here
I don't see that Donald Trump has posted
anything so we'll see the direction that
this goes there is a new morning consult
poll out from this week it has uh Nikki
Haley polling three percent of course
this poll was taken before she announced
her candidacy we'll see if maybe she
could get to four percent or five
percent based on this announcement right
now that tracker has Trump at 47
DeSantis at 31 Pence at seven and Nick
Nikki Haley tied for a heavily contested
fourth place with both Liz Cheney and
Ted Cruz so very very exciting numbers
uh for now for Nikki Haley the primary
is truly starting earlier than ever I
mean it is February we already have
multiple candidates by the way February
not of 24 but of 2023. one of the
Practical questions that comes up
is
do these candidates even really start
campaigning yet Donald Trump really
hasn't other than that one very low
energy event by the way in South
Carolina and putting out some really
strange policy proposals that are not
really policy they're kind of more just
complaints
um we'll see if Nikki Haley starts
campaigning regularly this is you know
if we think of July of next year or even
August uh probably July
um as as the end of the primary we are
talking here about a 17 to 18 month
stretch of primary we already have two
candidates it seems implausible that
they're just going to be aggressively
campaigning starting now but maybe the
fact that it's not just Trump running
anymore is going to force some of that
to get going so Nikki Haley if you
wanted if you're on the Republican side
and you don't like Trump you now have
someone who is actually running actually
running losing very badly to Ron
DeSantis who hasn't even announced but
it is it is at least an official
candidate let let me know whether you
think Haley will make any sort of impact
here
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman the link is down below